anyway i think we can just start right
here welcome back to the podcast guys
there you go randy bringing it home
what's up guys welcome back to the
chernobyl podcast the podcast without a
schedule for those of you wondering it's
been four and a half months since the
last episode and i don't know where the
next episode will be because it's all
about finding a good guess like a
quality guest like who we have here
today as well as finding the time to
just sit down and have a meaningful
conversation today we have randy tell us
about yourself
yo
i'm randy um
that's all you really need to know i
guess
and we just like finished the podcast
here no that's it i think we're pretty
much done
so
randy has a youtube channel uh in which
he's making
videos making devlogs about a game that
he's working on called arcane so you can
start i guess by just discussing what
that's all about what your plan is for
that game how how how's it going the
difficulties associated with that i mean
there's just so much to talk about when
it comes to making a game because it's
just such a difficult task
yeah i feel like we
we have quite a bit to talk about here
um and we kind of use that as a jumping
off point so i've been
i've been making a game for about
i don't know five years now um
and i kind of went into it just complete
just complete beginner like this is my
first ever game
um
and
yeah so i started out in unreal engine
and it was just
it was it was really just an act of me
googling how to make a game right and
that was honestly just the first thing
that i stumbled across
and then so i got into the whole um
unreal engine thing i think i
um took some udemy course on it and uh
kind of just followed along with that um
and that was really my first
um kind of
that's that's why i first learned how to
program it was in unreal engine just
like dragging and dropping blueprints
around
so it wasn't really programming but it
was visual programming and it kind of it
it's what wrapped me it's what wrapped
my head around the entire
um
the entire kind of
like yeah well i guess it's like
learning a new language basically um
that's what it is so so so what made you
wake up one morning and decide that
let's say i'm gonna make a game were you
like playing a lot of games at the time
and you wanted to
tell a story or
yeah i was actually playing uh daisy
standalone um
i don't
i don't know if you've heard of it but
um that happened
yeah so it's basically just this really
horrible game
all right well it's it's not horrible it
got off to a good start it's just one of
those early access games that is just
continuously in early access
and so i really got quite into it and i
was playing it one day
and i was like man the devs are just
really not updating this game whatsoever
i reckon i could do a better job
so then i was dead i was like
i'm i'm gonna go make my own game um and
and and don't better and faster than
these guys and um
that's really just not how it turned out
to be and uh
i kind of have a little bit of sympathy
for the daisy devs uh they're still
quite slow though but
um
wait wait wait wait that's
kind of like the zombie game daisy
like the mod for armor yeah yeah oh no i
know that yeah you said desi sorry my
bad yeah no no i actually used to play a
bit of daisy like back in the day yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it was yeah it
was a standalone version of that
yeah they made a whole uh standalone
version just i haven't played just on
steam and it was like an early access
that's right it was the stories
they basically launched it and just
didn't really do
anything with it at all and it kind of
stagnated yeah um and then i think they
switched engines at one point and um
just all that kind of stuff and then you
know it went backwards
and
that it's it's it's kind of nice to draw
that parallel because that's pretty much
exactly what i did
so i started off in unreal engine kind
of built out this um
kind of like a nice little prototype i
wouldn't call it nice but it was
definitely something right it was uh you
could walk around there were assets
there was there was a scene that was all
that kind of stuff
um
but it just got to a point where it was
so
um
just so poorly done because i literally
started programming
and had just learned everything so
just the entire game was built out using
um the
visual scripting blueprints that unreal
engine has yeah
and um yeah it was uh
the performance was horrible and
it was just if i had kept building out
that game it would have just crumbled
and just been a really really shitty
game
um
so yeah um at that point i was kind of
like
all right well i have to start again
it's eva i started grand
it yeah it's either i start again in a
new
um
just in another just blank
unreal project
and kind of try and do it a bit better
this time
except build in c plus plus
and try and be a bit more
i don't know
wise and yeah careful i guess would uh
be a good word for it um so yeah so then
i um
somewhere along the way i want cbos plus
um
so yeah and seatbelts plus with unreal
engine um is kind of just a nightmare
in itself i didn't really know it at the
time i was i was just like yeah this is
just how it goes i guess
and you compile takes what like
absolutely ages to compile and um
yeah it was just quite a horrible
workplace but
that did get my foot in the door for
running c bus plus and um
i actually googled how to learn t-bus
plus and um
i don't know if you heard of him but
there was this guy um i think his name
was like the channel or something and
so i basically weren't sipping
from you right
and um
you're literally my teacher you are who
taught me programming um honored
um so yeah and then i uh and i
i just kind of worked my way through
that um i remember the biggest help
was your video on pointers and that's
what really wrapped my head around
pointers
filmed in my parents kitchen
yeah yeah yeah while they were away in
europe
[Laughter]
yeah so um so that was good and then i
uh and then i got into seaports for us i
was kind of using that with um unreal
engine yeah then i got to a point where
i was like all right well i need to
rebuild this again
why don't i just
try and make my own engine
so then i actually followed your sparky
series oh man and um
old school yeah yeah and then and then
kind of just went like one for one with
that um kind of just like replicated the
sparky engine
um
up to a certain point where i kind of
just like launched off and did my own
thing like where i had enough knowledge
to
kind of like know how to google stuff
and uh just
kind of just uh yeah do it myself but um
that turned out horribly
it was uh it was just filled with memory
leaks it was all one object oriented and
it was just
um it was yeah it was just really poor
code
um but it was it was another step um
i wouldn't say it was a step up from
unreal because i took you know an
existing game that i kind of had you
know it was
relatively stable in that engine
albeit quite messy um
and then just made it even worse and
then
yeah so
um that was that was another step and
then um
so my artist at the time i uh i used to
have a pixel artist
and um
uh
so he was working for another guy called
ryan fleury
and uh i actually um
kind of just met ryan
that way
um throughout pixel artist and he was
making
a game from scratch with his own engine
uh he seemed to be doing quite well and
he was actually just doing it all on c
um
and i don't know if you've heard about
the uh handmade community mm-hmm yep
yeah yeah so um
yeah so he's actually weed on that now
um cool
um but yeah so he's kind of just taken
the handmade philosophy and applied it
to
just that entire telescope engine that
he has
and then eventually yeah i was um
i was kind of just sitting in my uh in
my siblings lost engine that i kind of
just threw together really horribly
um
and
yeah i was really lost and i was like
all right well
i like engine programming it's nice to
uh kind of just be in full control that
way
um
but
it's not really what i want to do you
know
i kind of set out on this whole game dev
journey to make a game
and i do prefer game design
um over um kind of just game engine
programming yep um so
i was like all right well
i'm not gonna completely reinvent the
wheel myself someone's already kind of
done that for me um why don't i just
kind of
see if ryan uh would be keen on letting
me uh use his telescope engine and uh
he was kind enough to let me do so and
uh kind of since then it's been about
two years since then and
i was thrust into sea and
um yeah just basically had to one see it
was uh
it was
very very jarring because you go from c
square sound into c
and you just don't have any of the uh of
the simplest plus standard library so
like no string no vector
and it really forces you to actually
learn
um
how to program properly um just without
relying on any of those as a crutch
yeah because
when i was first starting out you know i
would uh i would look at vector and
string and whatnot and um
just not really understand how they work
but just use them and be like yeah well
i know that string
gives me a string of um
just a string of text that i can use and
then vector that's a weight that's
that's always store multiple objects you
know
um
so
yeah and then being thrust down into c
it's like well now you've just got flat
arrays and
um just normal c strings and i kind of
had to
wrap my head around that but uh that was
uh that was really good and of course
the whole um you're not object oriented
anymore yeah
which is another like
thing that i was very
kind of shocked about um
but
um two years down the line um
it's definitely for the better and
i've just learned so much as a
programmer and ryan has been just
such an amazing mentor and um you were
an absolute you're an absolutely amazing
mentor for um
kind of just getting my foot in the door
with uh all that kind of seatbelt stuff
and uh yeah
thanks for that i guess thanks for your
uh nice educational content
happy happy to serve
um i was gonna say that yeah regarding
like the the c standard library versus
the c plus standard library yeah like a
lot of people would definitely agree
that that's a bit of a blessing there
not having things like vector things
like string because they are getting
better these days you know now we have
like context per strings and various
other ways to kind of uh not necessarily
let's just say bear the full performance
penalty of using some of these tools
without properly knowing how
but i think that
like i'm always torn between like when
i'm teaching someone fresh whether or
not i should mention
like implementation details and dive a
little bit deeper into what the computer
is actually doing because whilst a lot
of people deliberately don't teach that
because it's like a way to
overcomplicate things
for some people it's a way to simplify
things because it shows them what's
actually happening and the thing is you
open up the string header file like it's
huge right there's so much stuff going
on so much template magic but at its
core
like it is
and it obviously has a has a few
strategies as to how it allocates memory
as well but at its core it's really
quite simple it's just a series of bytes
of memory with usually a null
termination character that is fixed it's
it's it's immutable you can't change it
and so when you do start changing it for
example it may need to reallocate memory
same with vector as well it has a very
clear kind of if you look at the
implementation it is implementation
specific but it's got a very clear kind
of strategy for how it's like oh i don't
have room to store this new element that
you're pushing back so i will now
allocate a new buffer and try and copy
or in more recent times move that
existing memory over into some other
place so
i think not having that in c
you know
in in many ways has probably i would say
you know thrown you into the deep end
and accelerated that kind of lower level
programming ability in you that long
term especially someone who's working on
a game
where you have to be conscious of
performance
like i think that's that's definitely
benefited you a lot
exactly yeah and i mean
like you said it's actually not that um
i would honestly say that it's more
simple to learn about c-strings than to
even just touch
scd string in general
um
so from like a beginner learning
perspective i think just the way that
we're teaching in general is um
isn't really that good because we're
kind of just throwing all of these
abstraction layers at beginners and
being like yeah well you just kind of
take this for granted and just go use it
um
but if you just take like the just just
like a little bit more of a step
um and it doesn't have to be too like
much more difficult at all you can
you can teach c strings and just normal
um
uh just normal arrays and everything um
quite nicely
and uh
and it's
pretty intuitive once you do um start to
get the hang of it
um so yeah and it's just beneficial not
in the in in the long run because that's
actually how um how it works
so
why uh why go through the process of
learning scd string and scd vector when
you're eventually just gonna have to
unload it and learn how it actually
works to begin with um
in
just normalcy so
yeah yeah i mean it it is a bit of a
trade-off of like how much um how much
you want to
kind of throw at a beginner and not
scare them off i guess
um
but i feel like there's definitely ways
we can mitigate that and um kind of have
a better curriculum overall
yeah
yeah yeah and it's interesting because
like in our industry where like
again performance is quite critical like
the c plus
standard committee and the library is
not necessarily prioritizing performance
over things like usability and like
maintainability although to be honest to
be fair i don't know how
their code is obviously like so for
those of you who don't know every
compiler actually has its own standard
library so it's not like the committee
decides this is the implementation for
string this is the implementation for
vector it's kind of like with rendering
apis like opengl and falcon they're a
specification
and then it's up to the gpu manufacturer
in that case to actually take the
specification and write code for their
drivers that fits that specification and
fulfills it properly same with c plus
plus library so
the microsoft visual studio compiler's
implementation
is quite different from gcc or clang and
so because of that like again they do
prioritize different things and some
implementations are faster than others
and it's because we're in this kind of
real-time performance situation things
like memory allocations are way less
desired desirable than if you were
writing some kind of offline conversion
tool where maybe like it didn't matter
too much i mean i could i i would argue
that optimization is important in pretty
much every aspect of programming but
uh the point being that a lot of game
engines as i think it's less so recently
because the
the tools have become better but
especially like 10 years ago and with
different platforms like playstation
xbox like those
the game studios behind those games and
they're kind of engine technology they
write their own data structures a lot of
the time right so a good example is uh
because i worked at ea eastl right
that's kind of their standard template
library that is actually on github for
anyone to use
that is specifically
kind of
created with optimization performance
games in mind compared to something like
the normal standard template library and
the fact that if you are working in c
you're forced to kind of create a lot of
your own tools you could just use a
library obviously like some other
person's library and but i'm sure that
telescope has so many things built in
they probably have something for like
strings they probably have something for
like dynamic arrays maybe
uh there's actually none of that um
there you go it it it turns out that
when you actually start thinking about
this you don't even
really need any of that
i've like in my whole two years i've not
once needed a dynamic array yep um
you just allocate all your memory at the
beginning of the program
and you don't have to worry about
freeing or just
doing any of that um
if you kind of just allocate everything
at the start then you should be fine uh
if things do need to get bigger
it's either you change the fixed size
that you do at the start because you run
out of room and you know you're
expanding your game or something
or
if you do truly need something dynamic
it's really not that hard to yeah like
you said just write your own tools for
it but um yeah we don't actually
have any of that in at the moment
because we just haven't yet um all of
the uh
of the c string operations um just like
the normal c
standard for that um is really quite
nice um yeah there's just plenty of
stuff um
yeah that that's actually an excellent
point that's a step further than i
thought um
we were at but yeah absolutely
pre-allocating like memory at the start
of the program and then kind of diving
into that pre-allocated chunk and doing
whatever allocations you need
sub-allocations i guess yeah that's
that's an even better strategy and the
thing is for most people i guess using c
plus plus and using those tools
available they wouldn't even be thinking
about that i mean in hazel in my answer
like we don't we've done zero like
custom memory allocation and
it's not necessarily like i'm aware a
lot of people are like oh did you know
that this is far yes i know that that's
fast i know that's proper but it's also
about kind of well for us it's about
priorities and about like you know let's
maybe do the optimization when we
actually know the environment that we're
optimizing because it's more or less
complete but um
you know the thing is if i was using c
and if i was doing that i may have paid
closer attention to that which maybe
would have shifted my kind of priorities
in my roadmap a little bit
so like it's i don't know it's
interesting because these tools like
having them available like to me a lot
of the stuff that i've been using from
the c plus standard library has been
temporary in my mind but maybe that's a
bad thing maybe that's that's kind of
that's almost like it's encouraging me
to just
slack off a little bit and be like i'll
get but i'll get back to that later you
know let me just use these as a crutch
to just
get stuff done which
again is
it's it is a good thing but it can also
be a bad thing yeah exactly like that's
um
that's pretty much just exactly what
i've gone through like it was um
yeah and it is really
all right so if you
look at it from this perspective like
just that entire kind of mindset can be
wrapped up in if you go look at my first
video
arcane dev vlog number one
um it's
a whole lot more complete than my way to
step or complete
right um in terms of just features like
it looks like an actual game yeah but um
compared to like the skeletal mesh you
have at the moment yeah yeah yeah
but
it was like
i was leaning on just a whole
just i was just standing on top of just
all these abstraction layers that i did
not understand
and um
you know it's either you sh you ship a
game like that and you get something
like um
i don't know what's uh what's a really
nice
um
example of a
um of a really poorly performing game
um i currently think of anything off the
top of my head
what is something that isn't stable
yeah right
um
yeah so
um really cyber cyber trunk comes to
mind exactly yeah yeah unlike certainly
the old gen consoles
yeah yeah um
yeah it's really you have to ask
yourself this question when am i going
to actually learn this and online what
i'm currently doing
and actually just like learn how to do
it properly um down at this low level at
how
you know the computer actually thinks
and
um
yeah you're really kind of just
stripping away all the layers that
you're kind of leaning on as a crotch
yeah um and it's really just a matter of
time i guess i mean you can go your
entire career sure just making games in
um
you know unity and unreal engine all
that kind of stuff and that's that's
more than fine like a lot of people do
that um for example like danny he's um
he's just making he's just pumping out
games in unity and um it's great but
um
kind of have to ask yourself a question
of
um
do i want to make games
and do them
um
i don't really know how to word this but
right this very second do i want to
just pump out games you know or do i
want to invest the time in learning all
the tools
for like a good couple years all the
tools necessary for me to go down into
such a low level and have such a deep
understanding of
how everything actually works
but then later on be a whole lot better
off and like reach a much higher ceiling
than what
um someone currently using unity for
example would uh would be doing so
i've kind of taken the long haul
approach and as a result
it looks like i've taken just like a
million steps back and uh my way this
video is
um
like very
um
bare bones and like lackluster compared
to
what i was doing a couple years ago but
uh in the long run uh that's kind of
what i mean that's kind of what i'm in
it for um if i see
if i see a problem pop up like that and
i recognize that i'm winning on it as a
crutch i'll
it's a bit self-destructive but i'll
just purposely knock that crotch out and
learn how to use it properly um
so i feel like that's my biggest
strength but also my biggest weakness
is yeah is is that
that's that's really interesting that's
actually something that i've noticed
with your videos recently is
like every time i see them i'm like man
he's still on that on that like you know
kind of mesh of a person trying to do
animation and like the thing is to me
i'm almost like
that's amazing like that in a good way
you know i'm not like oh man he needs to
speed up because i know the work
involved in stuff like this and the fact
that you're able to publish videos and
not kind of take that pressure from your
audience necessarily to see the game
evolve faster because i feel like that i
don't know why i feel like that to be
honest it's self-inflicted
because i no one in my audience is like
man you're still doing this everyone in
my comments is like dude this engine is
turning out amazing like i can't believe
how much work has been done on it but in
my mind i'm like no no gotta have
literally like huge engine features
every week or every couple weeks and
that i know in my mind that this is a
cute like a bunch of tech that is just
growing and growing and growing and then
it's gonna crash first of all but also
like
you know
i it's not necessarily
true it's not necessarily real life this
isn't really what like if i was in if i
was a tech director on like an actual uh
in an actual big company working on this
engine i would not be producing this
would not be the roadmap right we would
be doing things a lot differently and i
think that if anything your latest
videos have inspired me
to make more boring videos that are more
true to what it's like to actually
develop this properly yeah because
having this fake image having this like
almost like a mask
is i think gonna hurt me like in the
long run
yeah and that's that's that's really a
really good jumping off point to um to
another topic um is like
just
you kind of creating um
you just
as as a content creator that's also
making um a game making an engine um
just
developing something uh you just feel
this constant pressure to
um go faster and
um just show all these cool shiny new
features to your audience
and that way you know you can title
thumbnail videos better
and you can bring in more viewers and
all that kind of stuff um
and i have definitely fallen into that
trap before where i'll um
i'll just go implement features for the
sake of implementing features knowing
full well that
i'm going to completely scrap this and
do it um the proper way in the future
and recently i've kind of just
i had a bit of a break for a while and
um
i got really deep i got really
demotivated um for making dev vlogs just
mainly because of that reason
and um
but then i came back and i'm like screw
it i i don't care what content i'm
making i'm just gonna do what i i'm just
gonna do what needs to be done yeah i'm
gonna wrap it up into a video i don't
care about
how how like how that video looks like
structurally from like a click-through
perspective like what i'm gonna title
what i'm gonna thumbnail it um
like i don't
i don't create features for videos now i
make features that i know need to get
done and then try and wrap that up into
a video
so and then
oftentimes you'll be watching a video
and it'll just abruptly end because i
just have not you know
wrapped it up and you know it'll just
you know and it'll and it'll just
continue on so
nice yeah
i i go to bed without with i go to bed
with the engine not compiling sometimes
it's not like
you know it's not like everything's just
rainbows and butterflies all the time
exactly yeah
this entire podcast isn't gonna be about
programming like we're not gonna just
blabble on about
um
kind of just this
niche chat between two programmers but i
mean like
a good portion of the people clicking on
this video are gonna be programs
themselves but that's not really like we
can't just talk for two hours straight
about programming so um
yeah there's definitely gonna be more to
this
um
than just that and i feel like we've
kind of just
gotten through that um nice little
programming segment and we can kind of
just
wait goodbye to it
all right mister
no programming chat what should we talk
about
well we are always gonna circle back to
programming
um but
um i don't know what's uh what's what's
like the most exciting thing going on in
your life at the moment
um
the most exciting thing going on in my
life at the moment
to be honest programming
well
to be honest like not much i mean i'm
sitting here in lockdown in melbourne um
so how much excitement
can one have
true very true
yeah i mean um
a bit of a downer bit of a downer
question
that's an amazing thing no i've got
something exciting i've got some
exciting things going on which i will
reveal um eventually when the time comes
uh yeah there are some exciting things
definitely coming um but to be honest
like i'm just
i'm i'm happy
to kind of be
in the space that i'm at right now like
when i first quit my job um which was
like
a bit over two years ago actually so i
used to work for ea for those who don't
know um on like game engine stuff so
when i quit that i was it was
interesting because
like i think that
at that point in time like i just got
married like i
work was kind of the last thing on my
mind like we we actually did this was in
2019 like my wife and i traveled so much
so we went to like japan for our
honeymoon we went to europe later we
went to like norway germany ever we did
we did a lot of stuff and it was almost
as if
we knew that like the following year
everything is going to be closed because
of kovith so um it was a really nice
kind of time and so one of the things
that
i did and that was actually one of the
reasons why i decided that okay i want
to take a break from work like we'll see
how this like youtube and me making like
my own stuff goes if anything like you
know i can always find a job i don't
think that's a huge always go back to it
yeah exactly yeah
yeah they they told me that if i if i
change my mind come back so i knew that
like i had a bit of a a safety net but i
just wanted to try and live like a
little bit differently and in the
beginning like if you go back to like
the second half of 2019 like hazel and
what i was working on
it was kind of in its in its early
stages and because of that like i think
that
it's so discouraging when you look at a
big project in front of you and you see
just
just how complicated it is like if you
were to like begin working on this huge
complex game or this huge complex game
engine or any piece of software really
you know even even stuff outside of
software like i don't know you want to
do some woodworking and build this like
enormous old-school wardrobe i don't
know um you know there's just it's so
the task can be so daunting and
trying to plan it trying to just
it can give you anxiety and overwhelm
you so much but yeah it's it's it's
almost like you look at um say there's
like 100 steps in the whole process
instead of focusing on like the very
first step you need to take you look at
steps 2 to 100
yeah you look at the other 99 steps you
have to take and you kind of just
but you really just need to kind of just
put the blinders on and just look at
that first step and just take it
and kind of just ignore everything else
um
yeah absolutely just just i think that
just doing doing the work just just shut
up and do the work just sit down and
start writing the code like that is
that just like stop over planning
everything just just yeah just go and
the thing is the thing is it happens it
doesn't just happen with indie
programmers or developers who have to
like be their own boss and set their own
schedule and all of that like i think
maybe it's it's a bit more kind of of a
problem there um because some days i
just like wake up at like i get up at
like 12 because i'm like dude what's the
point like i'm never gonna never gonna
achieve anything like this is ridiculous
you know it's kind of like depending on
it it depends on my mood a lot of the
time but like in the professional
industry as well like you know we had
game teams over at ea who would have
meetings
to
figure out like why they were behind and
those meetings would sometimes go for
the whole day and it's like it's like
guys like i think we had to like as a
kind of core team at the time we had to
step in and be like you know you guys
should really like you know not to
tell you how to do your jobs but maybe
if you stopped having meetings and
actually
told your engineers to start writing the
code
you would get more stuff done and
i think that like that's you know
whenever i feel like that i'm like okay
i don't care what's to come i don't care
that like oh no someone sent me a link
to all this cool stuff that unreal
engine is doing that i'll probably never
achieve like i don't care about any of
that let's put that out of the way
because what i'm gonna do is just focus
on the thing that i'm actually working
on the thing that i'm actually doing
and then i'll cross that bridge when i
get there
and
you know now now looking back at it like
the the whole reason i kind of started
this chat was because you know where
hazel is at right now like that's it
that's
so much like if i i i back then two
years ago i did not think i would be
here and the fact that i'm already at
this space where like you know people
have started actually making games with
it like we have some pretty cool demos
coming like it's got so many features so
many so many contributors have joined
the team as well like it's it's growing
so much and now
it's a completely different like game
right like the motivation i feel now is
a lot more than two years ago when i had
just started so a lot of it i think is
pushing through those first stages like
again whether it be a game you're
working on or an engine or anything and
then when you start to see the product
form like the first time you can kind of
drop into your game world run around
with the character interact with
something and it just it feels like
you're actually playing something like
that's an amazing feeling and that you
kind of keep you keep making progress
and the progress that you've just made
motivates you to make more and more
progress and that's just something that
you can only achieve if you shut
everything else out and you just
actually start working
exactly yeah
yeah you can kind of just get paralyzed
by um
yeah just having these unnecessary
meetings i guess but just gonna
get cracking and
you know the uh motivation i guess will
come from um once you actually start
getting the ball wrong
and speaking of getting the ball rolling
um this is something i've kind of
struggled with um
this is something that i am struggling
with um at the moment with uh with the
monthly videos
oh uh
so the reason i do monthly is because um
i have sponsors on each video and with
like sponsors you have to set like an
actual deadline
and get the video out on time
so that's been really good for um for me
structurally um
because i've gone from you know
uploading you know just whenever to
i now have to upload one video every
month yeah i don't have to like i could
for i could full guilt but i would just
be forgoing my paycheck basically um
so yeah it's been really good
structurally to kind of have that but
also it's
i'll get to the oh
i'll get to the end of the month and
it'll take me about probably about a
week all in all to um to organize all
the footage together edit it up
and um
yeah just kind of have it ready to
publish
yeah i mean i already yeah i'm in
exactly the same boat as that i've like
also got like a a sponsor like i
my sponsorship's a little bit all over
the place and i'm very kind of selective
about them not because i don't
necessarily like the companies but
because well first of all i i'll only do
it if i do like the company but also
because
like time because i know that that's me
committing to a video being out on a
particular date
and i do have like a monthly one with
skillshare but like
that
what you said there is so relatable
because that's literally me that's
literally me being like oh man i'm gonna
actually have to make a video
yeah like
let's sit down and do this but i also
use it as an excuse to be like all right
let's make a slightly better video than
i would otherwise you know let's put a
little bit more effort into this let
because you know obviously i want to get
as many views as possible not just for
myself but for the sponsor
um yeah and yeah that having those
deadlines and structure is actually so
good
exactly and if you can figure out a way
to um kind of just impose a structure on
your own work
like whatever it be um try and find a
way to set deadlines because they are
just so unbelievably powerful yeah
because without deadlines without
clear goals it's pretty easy to foil
around and kind of
just get trapped in this
yeah
paralysis of
over planning and overthinking things
and
um you're just not motivated to really
show up and actually get the work in
yeah but especially if you transition
from having a boss to being your own
boss oh god yeah yeah i think that's
difficult yeah
yeah just going um going independent and
all of a sudden you're
you've like kind of knocked out that
structure from above you you know you're
not working down to five anymore
um
that was definitely something that i
struggled with as well like just
just just waking up and trying to figure
out how to structure things like when i
when i first started i was just in
constant grammar like i would just every
like waking hour would be dedicated to
work and i'd be like all right
i've got to be focused on this just 24
7. partly because um
my circumstances of me actually going
full time um
i'll just like tell this story now but i
was uh
i was working as a barista um just at a
just at a coffee shop
that's secretly my dream job
yeah you know it's it's it's uh
it's good fun making coffees it's
actually quite therapeutic just you know
yeah pulling shots and
especially when um so it was uh
so it's called the raffles coffee i
don't think it's down in melbourne um
but
it is up in queensland and it's uh
basically this coffee franchise it's
kind of similar to starbucks right and
you've got like a drive-through and it's
really quite busy um
yeah just like kind of getting into a
good flow with that you just like sit in
that like just stamping in shots and
like pulling everything out you're like
a whole assembly line of people
and you know just like cars are just
zooming up like just like time just
slips away from you and you just like
all of a sudden it's under your shift
and it's quite nice but um yeah
yeah so
i um i just come out of high school um
and i moved to brisbane so i uh i
i grew up in a place called townsville
and um
so
as soon as i turned 18 i um
like i just finished high school and i
uh did a road trip down to brisbane with
my friends and we just moved here
and um
i had to get a job because i had to you
know pay rent
so
um when i was 14 i actually
got a job at zarathus and started
working as a business for a couple years
um but then when i got here
i was like all right well i need to get
a job
um the only thing i'm really qualified
to do is be a barista so i'm just gonna
keep doing that
um and originally the plan was when i
came to brisbane i was um
it was actually a startup uni so i did
go to uni
and i uh i did a bachelor of science
for about one week and then dropped out
and um
yeah i mean like all
all in the meanwhile so this is like 18
so i'm i'm already pretty much
balls deep in game development at this
point as well um
like at this point in time i think i
just uh dropped down and see bus boss
and started following your sparky series
um
so i still kind of had that constant in
the back of my mind like i really want
to do game development but i'm not quite
sure how to turn it into a career
because um yeah i mean i i only had
about a thousand subscribers at the time
i um
yeah that was like i just wasn't making
any money off of them um
so then yeah for about
eight months i kind of just dropped out
of uni and uh worked on the game a bit
more
and just worked as rapids for about
eight months
and then um
excuse me
and then at one point i got my tax
return
and it was about two thousand dollars
and i was like wow
this could last me like
two months or so if i really stretched
it
like three months even
so
i just walked into my job i was like all
right
peace
i quit
and uh and then and then got home and
kind of was just in this
mode of all right
i've only got a thousand subscribers but
i'm gonna make videos and i'm gonna try
and make this work
um so i was just in constant grind mode
from there that's kind of like waking
back to the point is
i was in grind mode out of kind of just
a um
kind of just because i had to like i had
that deadline of well i've got three
months worth of runway but once this
runs out i'm gonna have to go back to my
job or just like go find another job you
know as like a barista or something
somewhere else
um
but there's yeah like there was
there's always that backbone of like if
this doesn't work out um
i'm just gonna have to go back and find
another job and yeah you know it's it's
like yes it's a risk but it's not the
end of the world
exactly it's really not the end of the
world if you've got the means to do it
and pursue your passion yeah and try and
make it work go for it um because you
can
really just be doing job interviews if
you fail and go back and
you've got that structure again um yeah
especially if you're not like supporting
a family you know exactly just you then
you know go for it basically yeah if
you're young yeah send it and um yeah
i'm 20 years old for those of you who
don't know you're probably going to be
shocked to hear that because i look like
a 30 year old man
but um
yeah so
that runway eventually ran out and i
still didn't have a job like like i
still didn't have a career out of uh out
of youtube like i'd made some progress
but uh not really too much um
and then luckily my um
my dad he actually agreed to fund me for
uh for a few months i was like all right
just give me like a few more months i
know i can make this work
and uh he was he was
he was kind enough to fund me i uh did
up like a whole business powerpoint of
uh
of like my uh
my plan for you know like the next
quarter or so
and in that situation you know that's
that's that's where you want to do
planning you know to like communicate
your goals to other people but yeah um
yeah so i did that and uh he was on
board and by the end of three months i
um
i got my first video that uh actually
hit the algorithm and blew up it was um
it was
yeah conveniently in the middle of all
this i realized how shitty my c plus
boss game engine was and moved into c
and telescope and that was just like
another stress it was like yeah i was
down in this new
this new language
had absolutely no idea my
my um std strings and std vectors were
completely gone and i was just sitting
there just like
what do i do this is
this is horrible um
uh but yeah so
yeah and then i kind of let it just
learn um when i told it that way and the
first video that blew up was
i think was titled switching my game to
a new engine in one week and i had a
pretty nice thumbnail of like before and
after and i
slapped on some of telescopes um
pixel art uh shadow stuff and bloom that
um that ryan had going on and it looked
quite nice
um so yeah and that was uh that was kind
of like my foot in the door and that's
what sparked everything and um
yeah kind of just been going there since
and uh
cool
yeah
so this is those first videos
those first like arcane videos like the
very first devlog for example that was
in your sequels plus game engine
uh no so the first i would say i think
it was about six
that was in
uh unreal engine okay
so i would have been about
15 16 um
and then
probably from like i think it was
yeah that was just
it was it was just at one point it was
like seven to
thirteen or something like that that was
in the seatboss boss game engine yeah
right um in the sparky clone
and uh
yeah and then yeah eventually i hit a
turning point where i moved down into
sea and uh
oddly enough that was the video that
launched my um entire youtube channel as
well so it's kind of
poetic in that regard as well
um yeah cool
yeah
yeah i guess that's uh that's all there
is to my life story so far um
right now i'm kind of just chugging
along and uh
i've gone into a pretty nice routine
where i'll um
i'll wake up
and i'll go for a work session
and all my work sessions are recorded
live on twitch
um
and so yeah i'll usually just go for
about one and a half hours that's about
my limit that i've found um like
anything past that yes i can technically
still get it done but um
not as like cognitively sharp and yeah
will most likely make more mistakes than
actual progress so i'll kind of just
stop um
relax a bit uh go have some lunch uh
chill out
and you know go for a walk
and then come back and do um a second
session if i'm on a roll right so if i'm
if i'm like right in the middle of um
of the month it's not the beginning of
the month after i've just edited the
video and i've had like kind of like
some time off
um that'll usually be a bit of a slow
start or you should only do like one
session a day uh that's what i've been
doing for about you know the past five
days or so
um
then once i get into a good groove i'll
usually do about two sessions a day
maybe sometimes three sessions a day
of just one and a half hour work
sessions right um
and this is like serious work it's not
like i have twitch chat up and i'm kind
of like you know browsing twitch chat
and kind of like half in half out it's
like
most of the time i'm sitting there in
silence just programming and for some
reason people are still sitting there
watching that
um yeah it's pretty obvious you don't
have twitch shut up during the uh yeah
the switch to smooth shading
yeah yeah and then and then at some
points when i do get like um
really stuck i'll just you know bring up
chat and it's kind of just like a good
way of um
instead of googling something i'll just
say what i'm struggling with and you
know maybe some people will have answers
to that
um yeah so in uh in those situations it
it's it's great but i would say about 95
percent of the time i'm if i'm doing a
serious work session um chat
just won't be up um yeah
which is really quite good because
you'll go in the science and tech
category no it's called um what software
and games development now we've uh just
switched a new category
um on twitch
yeah it's it's uh yeah it's just
software and game dev which is quite
nice we've got our own little
own little home separated from uh the
people in science and tech who yeah have
streams of their docs which is lab coats
doing bunsen burner experiments or
whatever yeah yeah yeah exactly
um yeah so you'll just like browse um
software and game dev
and you'll just see everyone
they'll just you just like watch their
eyes for a little bit and you'll just
see them every like 10 seconds or so
just go
yeah and then just like constantly
checking chat yeah and it's
oh you have no idea how much flow that
breaks
you can it's it's almost like you can
never get into a good groove of
programming and go really really deep on
a problem
for a good hour and just get lost in it
because that's constantly being broken
you know questions are coming at you all
that kind of stuff um
well you know it's it's it's great
looking at chat and um interacting with
people but you kind of just have to
strike that balance of all right am i
here to get work done or am i here to
um
you know talk to people and kind of just
um
be a bit more shallow in um
in my whole approach to everything so um
yeah
yeah i mostly like i don't know when i i
try and live stream
often and every time i do a stream like
i genuinely enjoy it and i want to do it
again
but looking back on the amount of work
that i've achieved during a live stream
it's just so it's it's not like it's
very insignificant because apart from
when i do like i had like a um a year
ago i had like a vulcan week where i
basically
tried to move the whole engine from open
shell to vulcan
um that was like i had a very clear goal
i was streaming like six to eight hours
a day like that was i had to actually
get work done and so i didn't really
care about chat too much but like
usually when i do a live stream you know
i'm a pretty social person so i i like
to talk to people i like to answer
questions i like to just have a
conversation going one of the reasons
why i started this podcast so like
ultimately it's
that's why i i come back to streaming so
infrequently like once every couple
weeks maybe i'll do a stream because
i know that like in the long run this
isn't really gonna bring me as much like
i it's not gonna progress my tasks and
build this engine like the bulk of the
work happens when i'm got my headphones
in listening maybe to some nice calm
music or whatever yeah and i'm just got
my head down i'm just working you know
literally yeah yeah and um yeah so
that's the exact realization that i came
to and so then i started doing that and
i just stopped and i just stopped live
streaming um for like months
and i was just
sitting there working but then one day
i'm like all right what if i were to
just hit the go live button but just not
even act like i'm live streaming and
just continue working so then i started
kind of doing that um
now it's a little bit more integrated
with chat and i do treat it a bit more
like a live stream so i've kind of gone
back to my old
ways of um like the stream highlights
but
for the most part i've just i just hit
the go live button and i just work and
then i just stop and i'm done
and um
well then
that brings up the question well what's
the whole benefit to live streaming if
you're not going to interact with chat
and you're just rocking up to do work
um but there's
there's a couple of things it's like
well people are still watching this
which is kind of odd i have like an
average of about 200 viewers
and i'm just kind of sitting there um
i'll be thinking out loud and you know
just doing my whole thought process that
way
um and yeah i mean some people do enjoy
it
but then the other thing is um i've
actually
started just
making stream highlights on the second
channel and
just wrapping up um so i'll probably do
about
three sessions of one and a half hours
and that would make a second channel
video
um
and what that is is it's a way for me to
constantly
um
try and improve my
um well it's just like a constant
you know like two three videos a week
over there
and that's new people
coming into the channel learning about
you wanting about your entire project
yeah and it's kind of just constant
advertising basically
and then through
throughout that so i've um
so this is this can kind of lead into
the funding a little bit
um
so
one of the main plugs i do is like you
know if you've got an amazon prime
account you can drop a prime gaming on
twitch
and uh you can go to my website and like
link your account and just get a free
membership um that way
and so i'll just plug that in each and
every video and it's just like just like
a constant growth of primes
and um
just like a constant revenue stream so
that's my incentive for streaming on
twitch is that um
it is actually an income source even
though i'm sitting there in silence most
of the time
and um i've just figured out a way to
make that work
and uh you know it plays in nicely with
my work schedule and uh
yeah i really don't sacrifice
um
the whole
getting caught up in you know like a
distracted
streaming kind of
mindset um i'm kind of just like sitting
there working
so yeah yeah i mean it's quite nice yeah
i was gonna say that um the schedule
aspect of it is definitely cool you know
setting up an actual twitch schedule and
then you're like oh guess i'm getting up
at eight a.m tomorrow to get to work by
nine you know it kind of it simulates a
more active kind of office environment
which
i think is very beneficial to people
working from home on their own stuff
um definitely yeah just like finding any
way to
um put in some sort of structure some
sort of routine so that you've got
something to fall back on every day and
get into some kind of groove
um it's definitely probably just yeah
just step one in any
kind of independent journey when you're
um trying to work on your own passions
just
whatever it be like it like it doesn't
have to apply to programming or game
development or anything like you said it
could be woodworking it could be
um
just anything um one of my hobbies at
the moment um is actually djing so i've
so i bought like a
a um
a dj jack and kind of just weren't
um learned how to do that and i was
getting just so into it so unbelievably
excited about learning all that and um
starting like playing clubs and
everything
and
i was kind of just neglecting my game
dev so it was like well
i kind of really want to go do this now
but um then i was kind of um
interfering with you know my current job
and like my current source of income and
everything yeah so i've kind of had to
just take that deck and just like walk
it away in a cupboard and now i just
don't touch it because i know if i do
i'm just kind of gonna
go ham on it um
yeah i'm not very good at
multi-threading i can only kind of just
focus on
one task at a time
right um
even when it comes to hobbies it's like
i'll try and find a way to make my
hobbies a career and that's kind of what
happened with that whole dj thing yeah
yeah but i mean it's not that i'm not
gonna come back to it i've um i've been
reading a book recently called deep work
and um
the author was describing uh some kind
of um
um scheduling i guess to your work
and it's like
it's gonna be a whole lot better for you
to focus on one thing for an extended
period of time then focus on two things
for an equally you know lengthy period
of time yeah because you're switching
from one task to another uh it's called
it's called context switching yeah and
you leave residue
like attention residue
from the previous task and then it kind
of like it it stays around and you
struggle to switch into the new task and
it's and it kind of just like breaks
your flow that way
so what i've thought about this entire
thing is
well
if i am serious about becoming a dj at
one point
i'm just gonna dedicate like a good
couple of months to doing that and then
just take a break off the game yeah um
so now i'm just like working on the game
constantly and then at one point so in
december of this year i'm actually gonna
just dedicate a whole month to it uh
because you know it's like my birthday
month and christmas and all that i
figured it'd be a good time to do it
um
and yeah so kind of just
splitting up work
into that um
yeah i think the the contact switching
thing is um
[Music]
that's definitely important like so when
i worked at ea like i worked full time
so five days a week
and then what would happen is i would
come home like six seven pm and then i
would do youtube stuff and so
kind of during the day i was kind of
thinking about okay what video am i
gonna make tonight and how am i gonna
you know how am i gonna have time to
cook myself dinner and uh this is before
i was married said you know no uh
no dinner prepared for me when i come
home but um you know how am i gonna fit
in all of that stuff and then also plan
and shoot and edit a video like on c
plus pluses while i was doing the c plus
plus series
and so what i did is i went up to
my manager and i was like listen so this
is what my day looks like i get to work
i
you know work and then i get home and i
do all of this stuff
could i possibly
work for 10 hours a day here in the
office at ea instead of eight hours
and then have one day per week off
um and he he was happy with that so
monday monday and then wednesday
thursday friday i was in the office and
then tuesday i just had one day
dedicated to like
um to making videos and all that kind of
stuff and so that was really that was
beneficial to both things because i was
getting into the office at like 8 a.m
leaving at like six
and i was able to that that was it that
was an ea day you know that was
i all the time i was just plugged into
like
just doing ea work i didn't have to
worry about anything else and i think
that that definitely showed improvements
in both kind of the youtube stuff that i
was doing and also
my work at ea so
yeah trying to context switch less but i
i always like struggle with that because
i really like diversity i don't like
doing the same stuff over and over again
and i think that if you just do one
thing in a day that's not too bad but if
every day i wake up and do the same
thing over and over and over again that
really wears me out i like to do
different things and
um
with my hobbies as well like i have a
lot of things i'm interested in aside
from just programming and fitting that
in like how what's your work life
balance like when you're not you know
allocating a month to do say djing
um so
at the moment um
pretty much
um i would say
at like five o'clock so at
at sunset um just like everything before
that
is usually i'm thinking about game
development or
i'm actively in a work session
um or you know even when i'm on my
breaks taking a walk i'll be you know
just thinking about it and whatnot um
and just trying to like solve problems
um but then after five o'clock that's
usually when i kind of just say all
right shut off done
just like absolutely nothing after that
um
uh yes so then in that kind of like
recreational time oh um
usually what will happen is i'll just
lay on the couch and just kind of zone
out and just watch netflix or something
um
recently i've been getting into some
skillshare courses which has been quite
nice um
um yes so that's kind of what my
recreational life looks like um and then
occasionally when um
when my mates want to hang out i'll kind
of just like take a whole day off which
is what i'm gonna do
thursdays tomorrow i think
yeah yeah so um
yeah that's kind of what my um work-life
balance looks like um
i don't really take weekends off i just
kind of work every single day
i genuinely enjoy it um like you said
with um
you kind of get bored of just focusing
on like the one thing over and over
again
uh the way i kind of
work around that is
i'll have multiple
things
um that i really enjoy
surrounding
game development yeah yeah so if i get
sick of one thing so say i'm stuck on um
i've been kind of bad with this lately
but say i'm stuck on um
just that massive problem that i had
last video with um vertex skinning um
that kind of really just threw me off
but
let's say in a perfect world i was stuck
on a problem
um technically in the game engine
um i would then maybe just like switch
to game design and then um just do some
research on game design uh try and pat
out the story um just like constantly
just approach
the
um just the entire task of game
development from multiple angles
so you kind of just have like
subcategories that you work on
throughout the day so that's how it kind
of like stays fresh to me and um yeah
kind of constantly motivates me because
sometimes i'll be
really just demotivated with um with
like the programming side of like game
engine things um
but then i'll be like really excited
about you know this new
um gameplay idea or story idea that i
came up with and um that would kind of
just like keep me hooked in constantly
so i'm kind of fine with working every
day um
yeah i mean like
i would say probably like once a week
once every two weeks i'll just have like
a full day off and um
hang out with friends like usually i
like to keep it once a week having like
a full day off yeah but
um recently especially um i've actually
got to get this video out by the 25th
instead of the third instead of the 30th
this month because i'm actually um
going to be flying to um the northern
territory to spend time with my dad and
we're going to do like a
road trip
can't talk we're going to do a road trip
across the um simpson desert and just
kind of like drive back to brisbane yeah
so that's going to be pretty fun yeah so
right now i'm in full grind mode um yeah
obviously kind of just taking a bit of
break to talk to you and have a nice
little conversation today um but i would
like to get a work session in today um
yeah
yeah so that's kind of what my work
life balance looks like um
[Music]
it is a lot more work than um
some people would be comfortable with
but to that i say i don't actually do
much work each day
i do like
two sessions on average
like one and a half hours like that's
three hours of work each day yeah but
the fact that i do it so intensely and
so like concentrated like yeah
it's it's better to do that yeah than to
say rock up till nine to five and work
for those whole like
how many hours is that
eight
yeah yes
so like it's better to like kind of
chunk it up into um
into these sessions i find instead of
just sitting at your desk for eight
hours you know maybe having a lunch
break but
you know if you're sitting there working
on an issue for like four hours at a
time
there's gonna be like a drop-off point
for
proficiency at some point
and um it's like
are you really working or are you just
you know
kind of surfing the internet checking
your phone every 10 seconds looking at
email
um all these kind of different things
that
um you know kind of just say to yourself
like yeah sure i'm
i'm working i'm getting stuff done i'm
looking busy to my boss that's all that
really matters yeah for sure that's like
the whole four day work week thing and
like even three day work work
i think some people are proposing like
yeah it's
that can actually increase productivity
because people are burning out less
people are spending less time you know
with their mind wandering they're more
focused basically which is exactly what
you're talking about so yeah i
definitely totally get that what what
what do you do when you wake up when
when you wake up one morning and
you know you've got this stuff lined up
but for whatever reason you're just not
motivated
yesterday
that was yesterday so um
my alarm went off at like six i usually
wake up at six and just go for a walk um
but my alarm went off and i was like oh
i i'm i'm just feeling tired and i of
just turned off the alarm and just
laid back in bed and then struggled to
pull myself out of bed for the next
three hours
um
but i did eventually um get up and get
some work done but like for
for for the days when i'm just
completely demotivated so i'm working on
like a really tricky problem and it's
just like i
have no idea what to do i'm just stumped
um
you know
during those days you kind of just have
to give yourself permission to like be
you just have to make a decision you got
to be like all right
today's my day off i'm just going to
have the day off and i'm just going to
go do something that i genuinely enjoy
i'm going to go hang out with friends
i'm going to go surfing i'm going to
you know go for a nice walk just
treat yourself you know yeah
wife's life's not all about just rocking
up every single day and just being a
productivity machine over and over again
as like
as much as i love doing that to myself
and kind of just cracking the whip and
trying to just see how much i can milk
out of myself work-wise because i
i don't know i'm just
i derive some kind of enjoyment out of
that i have no idea why but um it can
kind of get out of hand and um i'll
some like sometimes i'll just catch
myself just beating myself up because
i'm not working hard enough but in those
moments you're kind of just gonna be
like
no
let's go spend time with friends and
kind of chill out and yeah there's
there's there's more to life than just
optimizing for productivity you know
yeah
not for sure
yeah but there's also like i mean i
think it's also it you need to strike a
balance obviously with that because some
somewhere i'll admit there's some some
days it's like the third day and i'm
like nah man just treat yourself you
know just just
just keep going and it's like i don't
know i've been playing hollow knight
recently um like on my on my switch like
in bed like a lot um and i really like
that game and i started playing that
game actually believe it or not as like
well because i wanted to first of all
but also as a bit of a research task
because i was like you know hazel like
the game engine series um is going 2d
only basically so there's like a hazel
2d is a thing now and
i need to look at some
good 2d games that aren't just you know
some kind of like you know the the the
normal like pixel art thing that a lot
of people are doing
um instead of that i wanted to look at
something a bit more higher fidelity and
and and hollandaise basically like these
massive you know hand-drawn environments
that are absolutely oh yeah yeah and
they're layered super well yeah
yeah really nicely
and to be honest like even though i was
kind of treating myself and i think i
got a little bit addicted
um to that game like for for a while
there like the amount of the amount i
think i've benefited from that has been
like it's been huge and i think that one
thing that i was doing because i don't
know i was never really that into
playing video games i would play them
for an hour or two
and then i would i would be like i don't
want to do that i want to do something
productive you know i want to make this
or i want to i was always like that as a
kid i wanted to make movies and i
studied films like for a while and i did
stuff like that kind of um on the side
you know while i was still in high
school i even did some freelance like
film and video work we made an ad for tv
you know
i i did quite a lot of stuff before i
was like no i actually want to go into
software engineering and i want to do
like i want to tell stories through
games not through
film basically and that was kind of the
decision i made
because i also really like the technical
kind of inter interactive aspect of it
and i think that you know that's why
i've always loved games that are
like works of art like i think and i
think hollow knight is is absolutely
beautiful and in that regard it's got a
great look like a great story it's the
environments are beautiful the music's
amazing like it fits together really
well but
yeah at a certain point it's like
okay
let's stop doing this like i'll get
angry at myself for doing that because
i'll be like no no no stop playing holly
night and it's it's not even me telling
myself that it's just it's almost like
it's just built into me it's like
go and work on hazel because you know
that that's like that is gonna make you
happier in the long run yeah producing
being productive you know producing
stuff being creative that's going to
make you more happier and longer in the
long run than just sitting here playing
hollow night and then
getting up
at the end of the day to make dinner and
then it's like well i just feel bad
about myself
exactly yeah yeah i mean yeah like you
said it's it's it's all about balance
and um
you'll kind of know that point when you
hit it you know you'll just kind of feel
a bit guilty about playing games like i
um
i had this recently with uh valheim
so i started playing valham with my
housemate and uh
we were kind of just like going on that
quite nicely
and he
he works like a night until
uh nine to five throughout the weeks so
um
but on the weekends um he would kind of
just have like free time and he would be
playing bellheim and um
i'd be like well i kind i kind of need
to get some work done but at the same
time
let's play bethlehem
so then yes i just like played belham
all day
um
[Music]
and uh you know there were a couple days
where you you know like i'd just do that
for like three days in a row
and uh
yeah but
i got into bellheim for pretty much the
exact same reason um it was like
when i first booted it up i was like wow
this is a really nice survival game
because like my like my thing is
survival games i
i really enjoy that whole
gameplay loop of like collection
crafting and um
you know playing with that and just kind
of like upgrading just like constant
kind of like um
yeah just that entire gameplay loop
right
um
so i was playing valheim and i was just
getting kind of like really motivated to
um like just to work on arcana and just
like go back to it
i would like i would just be mid like
mid game
playing with my housemate and be like
all right well
i'm gonna go dip and get some work done
because i'm really just genuinely
excited to go do that now yeah so yeah i
mean it's like
yeah um
i don't really know what it is it's so
important it's so important to
to play games as well and like
for me at times
i i
genuinely like at the moment i'm i'm
having a blast all these games like but
there's been times in the past where
i've had to force myself pretty much to
be like okay let's just let's just play
a little bit of a game and then when i
get well when i get into it it's like
okay this is fun i'm enjoying myself and
i'll get so many ideas and so much
motivation to continue what i'm doing
but it's like you know a lot of you know
film directors they watch movies a lot
like you know it's it's rare for them to
be like okay i don't want to i want to
be maybe for some special project
there'll be like no contact with the
outside world i don't want anything i'm
going to try and produce something
original you know like like artists will
lock themselves up in a cabin in the
woods to write an album but like
you know a lot of the time if you're not
actually you know
consuming
other people's work in your field in
your medium
i think it's really difficult to
to kind of produce stuff i i really do i
think that not just from the inspiration
and motivation side but also like
influence you know are there is there is
there anything that like what would you
say is influencing arcane like the most
oh so many things so um
the original mindset was so i was
playing daisy i was like all right i'm
gonna make a 3d zombie game um and it's
going to be better than daisy but then i
did a bit more research i'm like all
right 3d is probably not the way to go
let's turn it down a bit let's do a 2d
game um and i was just looking at
terraria i'm like all right i'm going to
make a terraria clone and then i kind of
set out to do that and then over time it
kind of just like evolved from being
into rare clone into just something
completely of um like
not um not like entirely original
because you know at the end of the day
your thoughts aren't original whatsoever
you're just kind of like picking
different areas of like yeah
like content that you enjoy and kind of
just like mashing them together like
that's that's that's how creativity
works i guess um
so yeah there was things like the
witcher i've kind of taken um
it's like kind of uh
just like the story kind of inspired me
with that um it's like the overall vibe
was quite like quite nice
and then
um
yeah so minecraft was a pretty big
influence terraria just kind of like the
whole
building mechanics and trying to build
something up
um
yeah and then
over time i'll uh i'll just tell you
what the game is about right now because
not many people actually know what
uh what the game is about or like what
my current kind of like
um vision for it is is it's basically um
it's gonna be like a 2d survival um
almost horror like
not like a jump scare kind of part but
more like a psychological horror um
so
um you're gonna kind of start off in
this area and there's gonna be walls to
each side have you heard of a kingdom
kingdom i don't think that's so it was
this really nice uh pixel art game um
it's it's it's that's that's where the
entire art style came from basically
um for my entire game is that's that's
that's where i got the art style from
because i just really enjoyed that um
it's kind of like
a almost realistic 2d um
realistic 2d pixel art
um so that's kind of what i'm
like that's that's the vibe i'm going
for visually yeah
um yeah so but you've got these walls
right and you're kind of just like in
this um
just like in this walled off environment
and it feels safe
and
so that's what i kind of want to
replicate with my game is uh you kind of
start off in this area and you're safe
and you have these two walls and you
kind of just have like a home base
but everything outside of that is just
like
you're venturing out into the unknown
and you kind of just have to overcome
challenge after challenge um the entire
storyline is uh
the seven deadly sins so you're gonna
have to face seven different bosses and
overcome each of the sins
um in one form one another like they're
not all gonna be physical bosses that
you have to defeat
some just gonna kind of be mental
hurdles that you have to overcome yeah
um but it's taken a lot more of a story
driven approach so there is going to be
a definitive story of um you going
through those seven sins then eventually
finishing the game um
and i actually just figured out the
ending yesterday for um just like the
proper ending which you know of course
i'm not gonna spoil but um
yeah
i'm really excited to kind of just um
just develop that out and get it going
um
some of the inspirations i've taken
survival um like just from the survival
elements like i was talking about
earlier with crafting
um
the original inspiration for that was
the forest
um so you like go down you like chop
down a tree and you'll you know pick up
those logs and go build like a log cabin
or something that to me was just like
there was something so beautiful and
peaceful
about you kind of just
with your ex just chopping down trees
collecting logs building a house it was
just yeah something so primal and
beautiful about that
and i would love to and i would love to
replicate that as well
um yeah so just like a bunch of
different little um games that i've
played over the years kind of just
i'm taking all my favorite parts of the
games that i've played and kind of
merging them into one um
thing i didn't really like about
minecraft but like this was kind of like
the whole draw of it basically is it's
um it didn't really have a story like
you just go to the end you kill the
ender dragon you like hop in and then
you kind of just carry on with playing
um
so i did like the whole sandboxing
environment um to it like that's
obviously like the whole drawers you
normally do anything but
um it was kind of just infinite and you
just there was no definitive ending it's
just ongoing until you get bored
basically
so
i'd like to improve upon that still kind
of provide that similar kind of feeling
of you have kind of like a sandbox in
front of you
but uh there will be just like a
definitive story which i've kind of
taken from um
i think
my inspiration for actually making it
story driven in the first place was
probably the witcher 3 right okay i did
get into that at one point and that was
quite nice very heavy story
yeah um
yeah so that's uh that's kind of how
i've like drawn on inspirations and yeah
yeah you know like you you collect
enough inspirations out of everything
and all of a sudden you're not copying
just one game but you're copying like
100 and it
makes its own thing entirely like it's
completely emergent and unique yeah that
way so and i think there's so many cases
in which
um you know you might play a game and
it'll spark
a completely unrelated
thought to what you're actually playing
you know so a lot of the times like i've
been playing holiday night and i've
hadn't like instead of being like oh i
like this element of it which has
definitely happened but
it's almost like oh what if this was
like this instead you know and you'll
kind of branch off into almost the
opposite of what you're actually playing
while you're singing so like i think
that yeah games definitely or any medium
really it stimulates the brain to think
you know and it kind of
gets those creative juices flowing yeah
you need that downtime of um
i watched this veritas video the other
day and it was um it was on the topic of
boredom and why boredom is actually good
for you
and you yeah you just need that down
time to be able to just make new
connections and think about things in
certain ways and
it'll just spark like just connections
in your brain and you just think about
these completely different things and um
you need to be bored like you need to
just put the phone away like just throw
it away 100 go for a walk or something
play your favorite video game um
i mean to be fair you're not really
bored when you're playing a video game
but um
it's still on like the topic of um you
spark new ideas from it you like
generate new ideas from it but like just
being completely bored like just going
for a walk or just sitting with just
being alone with your thoughts um yeah
that's how ideas are generated man yeah
yeah and you know like people these days
rob themselves of that so much you know
with the infinite like scrolling on
instagram or whatever on reddit
it's it's i think that definitely as as
a society like we've become way less
bored overall and i think that's i think
that's super negative like i think that
in my in my childhood my parents um
like they up until i was maybe 14 or 15
and i had to get like a laptop for
school
you know i was allowed basically
half an hour per week on the computer
when i was like eight nine ten years old
right half an hour per week and so
i would almost like i love what i love
doing is back in the day when games came
with like manuals i would just study the
game and i'll be like oh man half an
hour to play lego races or like whatever
other game i was playing you know i
would just start because i would pre and
my mind like i was imagining myself like
playing these games and how much i
wanted to get back to that and like yeah
i think that that made me such a
creative person overall
and i almost missed that because now
like no one's going to be like oh you
can't you know do this you can't play
this game you can't watch this movie you
can't scroll on your phone i really want
to do anything yeah i'm responsible for
myself but like
deliberately depriving my brain of
stimulation and you know getting all of
this stuff as well like i love doing
that because oh like definitely yeah
even like i mean
what's amazing as well is that i might
be working on something i'd be like i
don't like programming anymore this is
like you know i hate this this is this
is dumb it's not working it's so much
work i can't be bothered doing it i'm
gonna play a game instead if i deprive
myself of everything and i just like sit
down or like i go for a walk like
literally five minutes later it's like
i'm jumping at the opportunity to do
something and i want to do the
programming again i'm like dude just let
me have a computer i'm going to fix that
problem
it's super weird it's super interesting
yeah but i love it and
yeah i think that's that's so important
that's yeah that's that's that's exactly
how it works that's that's spot on it's
like
um
instead of doing that so say you're like
stuck in this problem and you kind of
just get bored of programming you're
like oh man i hate programming but then
you'll just kind of whip out your phone
and go away on the couch and like scroll
instagram or yeah twitter or something
if you do that
you're still at the end of that gonna
have the thought of like man i hate
programming as opposed to if you want to
just like walk out the door and go for a
walk or something or just kind of just
let yourself be bored
um you have that opportunity to
recognize the spark and then you know
get back into it
but whereas if you're kind of spending
your um
your attention on
things that don't really matter like
doom scrolling uh twitter instagram or
tick tock or whatever it is right
then you kind of you're you're
essentially just robbing yourself off
that attention and of that effort of
that energy that you could be spending
doing something that you genuinely enjoy
yeah um yeah so yeah i mean and that's
why that's why i unfollowed everyone on
twitter like i like i just
i was at a point where i would be
working and then you know
just like it's just like muscle memory
you just like
brewed up in your web browser you type
in twitter.com and then it's just there
and it's just like
oh yay free free distraction just like
an infinite timeline that you scroll
down yeah um yeah so i mean now that
i've just unfollowed everyone like it
was
i was i was kind of like trying to
justify it i was like oh well
i got to make connections i got to meet
new people through it um
i don't want to unfold everyone because
everyone will think i'm mean and just
unfollowed them um
so i was kind of like trying to justify
it that way but then eventually i gave
them like you know what none this [ __ ]
matters i'm just gonna follow everyone
and like yeah if people really need to
reach out to me they can
like i still have my twitter dms open
which is how you reached out and yeah
after waiting
yeah um
but like usually it'll just be like
email or something and like there's like
you don't need twitter like you don't
yeah i don't have i don't have instagram
installed on my phone anymore um i was
hooked on twitch on tech talk for a
while but then kind of recognized like
tick tock is like just the
the pinnacle of distraction over just
like all the
it's like the final boss of all the
social media apps dude just do yourself
a favor and don't worry
it is like crack like a lot of people
post youtube shorts though which are
from tick tock and i've kind of like i
kind of scrolled through yeah yeah yeah
i need to stop kinda get the idea of um
of that with like the youtube shorts so
you like hop on your phone you like see
the shorts yeah like kind of like scroll
through that
it's kind of a little bit of what tic
toc is like but imagine there's way more
outward than behind it yeah and it's
like
you scroll tick tock for like you know
enough time and it'll give you exactly
what you want yeah and it's it's it's
scary and then you just and then all of
a sudden like it that's that's just the
next thing you default to and you're
just scrolling take talk and it's like
you kind of have to make the decision
it's like well is this content genuinely
meaningful to me or am i going to forget
it in the next 10 seconds and not care
yeah most of the time you just don't
remember any of it at all it's all just
complete dog [ __ ] like you know
sometimes
um you'll come across some gems and
you'll be like wow this is this is quite
nice this is you know maybe like a funny
meme or something you share with your
friends
but
um yeah so maybe sometimes you will get
actual kind of good informational
content out of tech talk um
and you know various other social media
maps i like various other social media
apps
that was my justification for keeping
them in the first place it's like well
on my twitter timeline i eventually i
occasionally see um
you know something that is worthwhile
and valuable to me
yeah um
be like a blog post that i'm interested
in or something like that if you follow
like game developers or technical people
or whatever exactly but then you just
kind of have to be like well i can do
that
intentionally
from a different perspective so i'm
still on youtube right but i have this
app um this chrome extension which is
distraction for youtube so you just kind
of enable that it blocks out all the
recommended all the comments so you kind
of purposefully watch youtube but then
after five o'clock each time like yeah
when i um when i sit down to kind of
relax for the day i'll uh unblock it and
i'll just browse yeah
and um and intentionally and when i do
find myself in the workday um kind of
just like turning off that blocker and
kind of walking at that um even now like
i've kind of gone pretty good recently
because i'll see like a video that i
that i want to watch i'm like well
all right i'll just add it to the watch
later and then watch it at the end of
the day yeah so you kind of just get in
this mindset of you have to purposefully
consume content yeah
instead of
kind of passively just consuming
everything that comes your way like just
bookmark things um i've recently
installed this app what's it called um
pocket
it's called pocket and you and you
um say you find like an article or
something um you just like hit a button
and it just saves it to your like pocket
thing and then you can just like watch
it later or just like read it later on
um any device it just sinks across
everything yes um
yeah so that's kind of like a save like
like a watch later for articles and yeah
anything else that you want to consume
um but yeah kind of getting into that
mindset of purposefully consuming things
as opposed to passively through social
media and like scrolling timelines
because
as soon as you have an app with an
infinite timeline it's like it's just
you're not really just asking for
trouble you know
like yeah yeah so i've i've kind of
caught all those out of my life and it's
just
like it's just so much better
like i'm just
i'll just purposefully consume stuff and
enjoy and just not feel like [ __ ] for
doing scrolling you know um yeah
yeah that's yeah there's two things
there that that recommends you know
first of all yeah the whole like
clearing um you know your twitter and
all that like reminds me of ed sheeran
and how he just got rid of his phone
like for like a year i think i don't
know if he's still doing that but he
literally had an ipad and an email
address
that was it that's the only way you
reach him then no phone literally like
that i think that's that's a really cool
experiment like i don't think i could
ever do that but i could definitely get
rid of social media on my phone that's
the one like text and phone calls but
that's that's a really cool thing to do
i think um and i'm sure that it has so
many benefits but also
um what you were saying about
uh
what was it about yeah the the whole
like adding to watch later and then
pocket for watch later for articles
a lot of people these days they they're
so impatient they need it now you know
it's like oh i see an interesting video
i have to watch that now like delaying
that kind of gratification i guess you
know learning to put stuff you know on
hold for a little bit and not just jump
to it you know even like answering a
phone call while you're working i've
just started being like dude like text
me if it's an emergency i can maybe
glance at it but i'm not gonna not even
gonna answer phone calls unless they're
important you know during drawing stuff
i'll call you back later you know doing
stuff like that
um not only trains you and lets you be
more okay with priorities which i think
is just an important life skill but also
you know as i'm working i'm looking
forward to the fact that man five
o'clock six months i can get back to my
game i can watch that video i can't wait
to watch that video it just makes you
happier i think and being able to kind
of you know work with the motivation of
getting that reward at the end at the
end of the day so i think that's
exactly yeah um
that reminds me of this uh blog post
that i read the other day it was um
see if i can find it because it's a
really good read on this topic um
oh wait i'll let you know if i can find
it hang on let me just like put this to
do um fine is this
podcast just purely going up on youtube
are you putting up on spotify and
whatnot yeah spotify and
it all get distributed to basically
every podcast okay okay gotcha cool
all right um for the youtube folks right
now though um
uh there's this article it's called uh
why procrastinates procrastinate and
it's on a blog called wait but y um i'm
sure you can put it like in the in the
description as well if people want to go
if you want to read this um i'll explain
to all your audio people right now
though
um the analogy is basically we have um
it's this little dude called the instant
gratification monkey in our brain now
you might have seen like this ted talk
on youtube
about this guy kind of like just going
over this blog post
but there's just this instant
gratification monkey that just wants to
kind of just take over and
you know say
you've just glanced over at youtube and
now you see this youtube video and it's
like well we have to go watch that right
now we we have to stop everything we're
doing and go watch that right now
um
so that's kind of what the instant
gratification monkey does but then when
going back to what we were talking about
earlier
is um
i think in a sec
when um
when we were talking about uh kind of
just like taking that youtube video and
putting it as like a watch later like an
article or just whatever
you're essentially getting the instant
gratification monkey to work for you
because instead of you
being motivated to go do that right now
you kind of say all right let's get our
work done and then we can watch that
afterwards
and it's like
the
the monkey isn't as happy about that
idea but he's still happy about it
because we do get to go you know play
around and have fun at the end of the
day and then as you like get to the end
of the work session you can probably um
you can probably
um also what i'm looking for i can't
find it
relate to this
a little bit is like when you're at
school and it's like the last like hour
of school i was like 15 minutes or
something and you're like watching that
clock tick down you're like well i can't
wait to get home and play video games
with the boys or something like that
or like you're just at work or something
right
and you just like can't wait to get home
and um
go relax and
do whatever it is you
kind of like
want to do like video games um you know
watch youtube whatever
it's just like that feeling of like well
i can't wait to get my work over and
done with so i can then go do that like
that's what this entire kind of like
thing is and if you can kind of leverage
that then
you know you can
yeah you can just
you don't have to constantly beat the
mercy of the instant gratification
monkey
yeah and uh him kind of steering the
ship and
leading you into watching a
um three-hour podcast which is probably
what a good chunk of you are doing right
now on this video instead of hitting the
watch later but that's okay you know you
can you
you've already made it
you may as well finish the video
hopefully yeah yeah hopefully
but what you really should have done is
you should have seen this video save
this to the watch later and then watch
it after 5 pm today but
better look next time all right or you
should be listening to it on spotify
while doing some exercises or doing
something productive like cleaning the
house that's what i do
so much fun
yeah yeah just like popped in a good old
podcast you're like going around doing
some vacuuming or something and going to
the gym
um yeah it's like you're just kind of
gaining back that time that otherwise
would have been spent doing some
um
you know some
meaningless tasks not meaningless but
you get what i mean less meaningful
yeah less meaningful yeah i think that
um
uh definitely like
delaying that
gratification that pleasure if you will
is also
it's just
i think it will
it it
it increases it you know like i i think
that yeah i think that if you're able to
be like you know this i tonight i'm
gonna do this amazing thing like if you
do it during the day
you know if you're doing it all the time
then it's not special anymore you know
this is meaningful i used here's a great
story i used to well i still do i really
love dumplings like i just love
dumplings man getting some chinese
dumplings oh my gosh my one of my
favorite fruits right and there was a
time when i just started having it like
every week and then after a while it's
like well i this isn't special anymore
like i used to with the boys we used to
just like literally once a month we had
a dumpling run and it was just so good
but then when i was like well actually i
can just ubereats or whatever this
dumplings just come to me you know i
started doing a lot more often and i'd
be like well you know i was working all
day i don't have time to make dinner or
whatever
i'll just order dumplings but then it
loses that like it becomes worse like
the experience of what used to be so fun
and so nice and so good you know whether
it be playing a video game or you know
watching this this you know your latest
content cr your latest favorite content
creator has like released a video you
know
delaying that and then saving it it just
makes it so much better and it doesn't
lose its charm so i think that's awesome
people just you just you get used to
anything you know i think like another
big thing is monetization yeah people
struggle with this a lot with money for
example you know they're like okay well
if i could only make this much per month
or if i could only have this much money
i'd be happy but then you get used to
making that much money and it's like
well i i want this much money and i want
more and you just get used to it and
it's not special anymore and i think
that with some things you can't control
it but with with other things you can
definitely be like no i'm gonna continue
having this schedule even though i am
now my own boss i'm gonna continue you
know structuring my days properly and
getting up at a reasonable time every
single day as if i did have to rock up
in the into the office at a particular
time because that's going to just make
me a better person basically
exactly yeah i mean you could binge
watch netflix you could go watch all the
seasons right now or you could have one
episode a day and make it something
special that you walk for exactly
yeah 100 um and it's it's really hard to
build up that circuit in your brain
because you just like you just want to
just go do it now but
once you kind of build that up and uh
kind of just practice it a little bit
more it kind of becomes a habit
um that's when you know it kind of turns
into something special and
yeah you're just looking forward to your
reward at the end of the day or whatever
it is and
you're not um
just constantly in a state of
desensitization where you're just
exactly
stumbling around and
consuming everything you know um
yeah for sure you know we we were
talking about balance earlier and i
think that another thing that i just
remembered as well was
you know because you're kind of in the
same boat as i am in the sense that
you're both developing software and
making a game but then you're also
making videos about it and so you said
that like one of the things that helps
you i guess balance that is the fact
that if you are streaming that produces
video content that you can then take and
make it to your videos but other than
that like how to because i'm still
struggling with this like i'm still
struggling to find the balance between
like you know i want to make videos and
not just devlogs and not just like hey
this is what i did today but also like i
like education and i like to produce you
know obviously i have like the c plus
plus series and like i made a video
about bloom recently and how that works
and that took me so much time and it but
it was so much fun and i love doing
stuff like that but i'm still struggling
to be like okay but i have to make this
game engine and like i have to make this
game engine series and i have to make
this like a c plus plus video and i have
this how do you how do you find the
balance between that have have you ever
thought about just
cutting some of it out
like some of the
like at the end of the day like yeah
sure you can do all these like different
things and kind of juggle them all
but wouldn't maybe you prefer to do one
or two things really really well than
doing five things kind of
mediocrity
not mediocre but like less quality than
what if you were just focusing on them
because then you kind of like
like it's not like you can't get the
other things done you just put them in
the future you kind of just prioritize
one thing over the next so i think at
the moment you're doing so you're
working on hazel
and you have um a game engine series
like the gaming series hazel which is
like a different version of hazel it's
like a 2d version i think i watched that
video the other day
and um
have you ever thought about just
completely discontinuing that 2d version
of hazel and then kind of just switching
completely to the new hazel and making
devlogs around that
and kind of just like
you still make educational content but
on the 3d stuff i think what you said
was it's more technical it's more
in-depth it's like kind of hard to do
educational stuff on it yeah but maybe
you just do like
yeah yeah like more just
um
i don't know maybe like
devloggy stuff relating to that like
educational content has its place but i
think it has its place when you sit down
and you say instead of like um
um how do you do your educational stuff
at the moment is it like pre-plans and
you have like a structure or is it you
just sitting down trying to figure
things out yourself and like going
with the flow it kind of depends on what
particular educational kind of content
i'm making like you could call the game
engine series educational that's pretty
much like i i very loosely planned that
it's kind of live people people i've
tried kind of rewriting the code ahead
of time or like writing the code i
should say ahead of time then kind of
merging it in or whatever and explaining
it people don't like that as much as the
live coding stuff so i've tried to keep
it as live as possible people like to
see me debug issues and have unexpected
things happen so that kind of requires
no planning but c plus plus series and
like when i did the opengl series and
stuff like the bloom video like that is
um that can range anywhere from dot
points where it's like okay don't forget
about don't forget to mention this but
the actual dialogue is all live and on
the spot yeah yeah but then the bloom
video was like entirely scripted
basically apart from the kind of some of
the screen sharing kind of if we look at
this it's that and all of that yeah yeah
okay um
yeah i mean it just sounds like you have
a lot on your plate at the moment um
yeah especially with like the with the
hazel you've kind of just like split
that into two
um
the way that i justify that though as
well because like yeah i've definitely
thought about discontinuing the game
engine series but the way that i justify
it is if we're working on the 2d version
of the engine like 2d is something that
i want
big cases
right and i'm not working on 2d in fact
i'm not even working on ui like hey the
proper hazel doesn't have any kind of
in-game ui that you can create either
yeah those are all systems that i'm
going to develop as well as as good as
possible like to the highest standard
possible in hazel 2d and then merge them
in just like with like a lot of the
stuff that we already have like the
scripting runtime for c sharp and
everything in hazel and big hazel that
can also kind of make its way like i'll
know what i'm doing when i start live
coding that so
i've tried to not do the same thing i
was pretty upfront about this like a
couple of years ago i was like guys i'm
just not gonna do this like i'm not
gonna write the same engine twice like
there are other things to do not to
mention that like the game engine series
because it's got like over 100 videos
which people kind of have to watch if
they want to
still benefit you know a lot from the
latest videos like the viewer base for
those videos is quite small because
who's going to watch 100 videos
specifically on this and want to watch
someone live coding for 45 minutes
unless they're either really invested or
it's just for fun for entertainment like
hey let's watch that
that kind of draws parallels to have you
heard of a
handmade hero yeah
yeah yeah so um that's uh
i don't know how to pronounce his last
name casey
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah so he's kind of been doing a
similar thing to you in that regard
where he's kind of just um
he's taking a game engine just like
completely from scratch and kind of just
like coding it live and doing everything
like that
um
but if you look at that he's he's he's
been doing that for years and yeah you
see this entire 600 massive episodes
massive body of work exactly and it's
like there's way too much yeah of an
upfront investment in order to get
started with that exactly so i really
struggle to um
i have people come on stream or just
like just like in the comments and be
like alright i really want to get
started doing what you're doing how do
you do it and i don't really have a
a good place to direct people to because
um
you know the way i've taken certainly
isn't the most efficient one i took a
udemy course on cbosplus blueprints and
um and then like stumbled across your
content and then
i was mentored by ryan with c and that's
been my entire last two years and
it's like
we need a nice place to kind of just
direct people to so you can just like
sit down like all right take this course
and you'll be good
yeah and like from there you'll learn
how to problem solve yourself you learn
how to google you learn how to do
everything and um
i don't have a place to recommend people
that at the moment um
really so i mean
um going back to you like with your
current sibling stuff um how how big is
that like how many
how many episodes do you have in your
whole c plus series
i want to say it's around 80 but i have
no idea
to be honest
yeah so i mean from that perspective i
guess if i like if i were in your shoes
um what i would really want to do would
be try and figure out how to condense
that more and more and strip away all
the unnecessary stuff and try and like
like it's like you just keep making the
same tutorial series over and over and
over again until you've just got its
complete essence and yeah that's like
really nice for beginners to look at and
do
um
as opposed to kind of just like doing it
once and leaving it up and then being
like yeah you like here you go but
there's just like a lot of work with
that and i don't think it's um it's kind
of just something you have to keep
iterating on so maybe maybe you could do
like a um a partnership with skillshare
or something and then like
do up like a uh like a new c course or
something or yeah well what i've what
i've wanted to do for a long time
actually is make some courses and i
looked into making them for you um you
to me
but
man i i don't know i still don't quite
understand their revenue split but
apparently if someone if if someone buys
your course not off of your link your
special link but they just find it on
you to me
they take like 70 percent of the money
or something
and i was like i was like that's
ridiculous right yeah and so
what i decided to do and what i'm kind
of currently working on which i haven't
talked about too much as well is
like i want to basically make my own
website and then
have courses there that people can buy
and yeah like i'm currently working on
one for rendering because i just want to
make the best rendering course like the
internet has ever seen like that's great
yeah almost almost all of them out there
are like
okay guys let's learn open gls learn
falcon and then what you get is you just
learn the graphics api like you just
learn like this is how we draw a mesh
like none of that i want to start with
like a beautiful 3d scene that you would
be proud to print and hang up on your
wall as a piece of art that's what we're
making that is that's the goal of this
series that'd be such a good hook not
just like showing that exactly
that's exactly what's gonna happen and
then along the way it's gonna be like we
might even start with a bass kind of we
probably will start with a bass kind of
application framework that already has a
game loop and like all the kind of stuff
so that we can focus on like
specifically like the graphics
programming part not even not even to do
with say opengl or vulkan that much i
mean it will use one of those apis and
we will talk about that but it's more
about like
you know exactly like the actual
algorithms that go into this how to
achieve these techniques how to render
that beautiful thing you know and uh
that's something that because it's not
going it's not going to be on youtube
like first of all i can spend more time
on that because it's such an it's kind
of a niche thing but if people are
paying for it i can make it better
because i can spend my time on that yeah
exactly but also i can update it over
time if i decide that my explanation for
that was rubbish or something has
changed because it's now the year 2025 i
can update that i can open up that video
add a little segment or like change it
even or re-record the entire segment
whatever you know i can keep it going
over time which is not something you can
do like what you were talking about with
the seepless plus kind of essence series
like i take the best but i could keep
condensing it i could ultimately maybe
not to that degree but like i could
continue updating that over time and
making sure that it is just the best
resource available
so that's something that i would be
super excited about yeah yeah that is
awesome yeah and then just like
developing your own website forward and
kind of just yeah
you just you just take like a hundred
percent of everything exactly like that
would like that just be great um yeah
and then all you'd have to do is just
post the introduction video up on
youtube and that's how you lead people
into it you know yeah
and uh then you know finn like the um
the only
uh
what's the word um
the only benefits to using udemy or
skillshare is that existing ecosystem
yeah if you don't already have good
weights
exactly so like then there's just no
point in using them
if you've got your own kind of way of
marketing it and um you know just
bringing it to people
so um yeah that's like the same thing
with like steam and everything um
like i actually plan on
i just plan on releasing the game for
free on my website once it's done
like i mean i'll like i'll still
probably put it up on steam or something
and i'm sure it'll still get distributed
while like switch and everything and
we'll have like a
price point but
the main meat of it you like
i don't really care about the money at
the end of the day like i'm earning
enough to just keep doing this
indefinitely through like through my
current website fund yeah and to me
that's just amazing like the fact that i
can just work on this and not have to
worry about paying the bills and then
all that's just covered
um i i don't really care about making
millions of dollars off of like a game
release like i'm just gonna
i feel like just popping it up on the
website and just giving it to like for
free for people and it's like if you
enjoy it sure donate like
that kind of like itch.io model how you
um yeah kind of pay whatever you think
it's worth um
that really resonates with me and um
to to the point where i'm actually
thinking about um
so right now i um
i run everything as a sole trader um do
you do that as well yep
yeah so um i've gone to a point where um
i'm like earning
um so much money that um i'm hitting
like some pretty big tax thresholds yeah
so it would make sense to uncover that
feeling and yeah
yeah and it would and it would um and it
just like makes sense to incorporate um
yeah actually like a company it's like
flat 30 tax for the company
i think it's 25 even oh really has it
gone down yeah i thought it was 30.
i don't know that was that was um
maybe i might be just remembering the
discussion but for those of you who
don't know who aren't in australia the
last tax bracket is like 45 percent
so it gets pretty high yeah yeah i mean
like the one i mean at the moment is
about 30 um
but
yeah that's just obviously just just
with like no growth over this next year
which is
already i'm off to just like a walking
start like yeah um so the way i earn
most of my money at the moment is
through um
the sponsorships on the video so monthly
i've been kind of doing that
then recently i've um just developed out
a whole um a whole font on my website so
it's kind of just like patreon but it's
just like all yeah um just like built
from the ground up basically
um
so i've got that over there and um
yeah like that's like that's starting to
pull pulling quite a bit of money now
like we're at about
3 400 a month just off of that and um
yeah like it just keeps going up and we
kind of just like have like just keep
setting goals for everything and
it's not like i'm just
um trying to get more money for the sake
of getting more money i want more money
so i can
like
put it into more resources hire a team
like get more development going all that
kind of good stuff yeah and um
so i thought well
if i don't actually want to make a
profit at the end of the day there's no
real point incorporating and doing any
of that why don't i just become a
not-for-profit
oh okay and do that so
i've actually got to go in 20 minutes
and talk to my accountant about that
that's that's that's why i have to go at
midday because i'm actually gonna like
walk into that a little bit more oh cool
um
so yeah i mean just
yeah i think that could be a pretty
viable option i don't know because i
think that would just get rid of all the
tax concerns
yeah because what i was gonna say
actually when you mentioned that you're
not making a game to make millions of
dollars i was going to mention that i
kind of
hopefully am hoping to do that but the
reason being that i can then spend that
money
on creating a game studio you know and
actually yeah exactly actually doing
what i enjoy because like i feel like
that's why like a lot a lot of people
you know look at money as like this
negative thing but it entirely obviously
depends on what you use it for like i
don't think i would ever be like oh yeah
i'm happy with this and i never want to
grow beyond this kind of amount of money
that i'm making because the more i grow
the more i can start hiring people you
know
um and the more i can expand um and
that's such an exciting thing exactly
yeah
yeah and that was that was my exact
reason for starting this out to begin
with i was like i really want to make a
game studio i want to make a game i want
to hire all these people i want to get
offices i want to do all this cool stuff
um
yeah and and so that was my whole reason
for kind of earning a profit at the end
of the day and making millions and you
know that's still something i'm gonna do
it's just it's gonna hopefully be enough
for profit and you know like it's like
it's like it's not like you can't make a
profit
uh in enough of profit you can still
earn money
but you just have to allocate that money
towards the mission
and not run at a profit if that makes
sense so how much are you allowed to pay
yourself from from that i guess um so
it's work and
yeah i'm not too sure but um currently
um what i would do is i would only pay
myself a max of 700 a week right because
that's i think i think like my math
might be wrong but i think that was the
threshold for the 25
okay tax bracket right um and like at
the end of the day i don't really need
anything over that like at the moment i
pay myself about
i think it's about 400 a week um and i
can kind of just like live off of that
quite comfortably um
so yeah i mean
yeah i can't remember where i was going
with that but um
yeah i yeah i think 700 max maybe i'm
not exactly sure the number but
um i'll just take whatever i need
basically
yeah that's an interesting concept i've
never thought of that
yeah and then like i mean
you're still kind of in it for that
whole idea of making a studio and
everything yeah it's just you're kind of
doubling down on the idea that
that's what it's for like you're setting
admission and you're doubling down on it
and you're saying to everyone
i'm not here to make a profit yeah i
think that's that's the whole vibe
that's going on
because right now
i've got quite a few people just um just
just just coming to me and be like i
really want to help making the game um
but
right now to get access to my source
code well first of all you have to
become a member on the website so you
have to give me money to get access to
the source code and then people are then
saying i want to help contribute to this
and it's like
i don't feel comfortable with that
whatsoever because
you're giving me money for the
opportunity to contribute and i mean
like
everyone's fine with that like i've
talked to them about it and they're like
you know it's all good man i just really
like what you're doing and yeah
that's great but
i just don't feel comfortable with that
you know
uh because i'm a for-profit company and
it's
like i feel like i'm kind of
um
um
kind of word this
taking advantage kind of taking
advantage of people yeah yeah literally
yes sir but if i'm a
if i'm not for profit that kind of goes
away and it's like well we are really
building a community here and
you know i'm kind of just doubling down
that whole idea so so the way that i got
past that because i'm in a similar boat
as well right people
people subscribe on patreon and then
they get access to big hazel and then
they want to also help me with it so
um the way that i okay so first of all
some of the there's about eight people
on the hazel team
about half of them are patrons right and
i don't again i i have never been like
yeah you need to keep paying this
otherwise i'm going to take away the
code that you wrote essentially
[Laughter]
um half of them are not half of them
have come up to me and they've pitched
me just amazing like just they've
they've been like look i really want to
contribute to hazel and
this is what i want to do
and then they had they've never been
patreons but i've obviously given them
source code access and i've kind of put
them onto the team and the reason is the
reason that i consider that kind of okay
is because first of all like making a
game engine there's so many different
systems right so if someone just loves
audio programming
and they want to program audio for an
engine
they're not going to make the rest of
the engine you know where are they going
to be able to practice their craft right
i think coming in like that we have some
networking guys as well who are who are
hoping to hopefully take hazel and make
it multiplayer as well and kind of
architect all of that they just love
network code and they want to contribute
that to a game engine but they also and
they started off there i had a
conversation with them recently they
started off making their own engine and
they're like i don't care about
rendering i don't care about all this
why don't we find a good kind of project
that's out there and then we can we can
work on our stuff and we can get better
at working on networking code which we
care about and we can also contribute to
something right that's amazing
so i think that experience is really
good but also some of these people like
uh some of them have had professional
experience some of them haven't but
they're just really good programming i'm
shocked at the level of quality from
some of these people like when i found
out that like some of them have never
had a programming job i'm like are you
joking you're better than half the
people on the team at ea like literally
like it's amazing because it's just raw
passion that goes into it yeah
and the thing is what what i'm kind of
offering them i guess is
a lot of mentorship because i spent time
on discord you know having calls with
these guys and they're like look i want
to do this system i've never done it
before can you help me out and like in a
way it's like you know i'm they're kind
of under my mentorship obviously i've
had professional experience working on
game engines at ea like i kind of more
or less know what i'm doing although i
would say that there's obviously a lot
that i don't know um but like i know
what i'm doing i can kind of direct this
project and they have the benefit of
also adding me as like a reference you
know if they want to get a job they can
be like look i worked on hazel i did the
physics system i did the audio system
whatever you can check it out it's a
real project it's got a website it's got
youtube videos you can you can look at
this so i that's the way i kind of see
that but also
overwhelmingly
they just want to they just love it you
know it's just their passion they want
to work on this like
you know i only have one employee who's
actually on payroll a software engineer
right
and i and as the patreon expands as
everything expands i plan on hopefully
being able to
you know pay some of these volunteers
and basically get them to allocate more
time onto this and make it more than
just a hobby for them right that's the
plan overall
but like
them being there i think is it's just
you know it's just something they're so
passionate about and that's such a great
little team and community that i've
built up oh yeah
and
i've come together
yeah if you just stitch together a bunch
of people from dis from different
disciplines that are genuinely
passionate about what they do yeah
it's like that's exactly why i sold out
ryan because he's really passionate
about like the game engine side of
things
and i like it like i can do it but i'm
really really passionate about game
design
so um that's kind of where i come from
and it's like
that's what i want to spend most of my
time doing um so it's just to have these
people who are also passionate about
what they do and we all kind of just
like fit together like a jigsaw
like
you know yeah that would be really
amazing i was gonna i was gonna ask you
what your favorite like part of the
whole game
development process was so designed yeah
it's way around yeah it would it would
definitely be game design and
like
i do still really like programming but
um just in terms of like just game
design like just figuring out loops like
trying to
give the player a nice experience
um i really enjoy that yeah
obviously i haven't done much of it
because i've just dedicated like the
last what five years to learning how to
program properly yeah i've done a little
bit of game design and i'm kind of just
you know
quietly sitting here crafting an entire
story an entire game um just in my
notebooks but um
so originally i um
i hired a pixel artist just when i was
first starting out yeah
i didn't really hire him i was
i was like 15 at the time and i just
promised him royalties and
yeah and i was just like yeah that's
just like all right bet
and then um so then i got pixelated that
way and i also met ryan through him as
well right yeah um but yeah and then
er and then over the years i was like
all right well
um i need to just hire a pixel artist to
just get him to do all the art for me um
but then i was like all right why don't
i just do it myself and then i just want
my pixel out myself yeah and that kind
of just did everything um
you know like it doesn't look as good
but um you know it's getting there and
it's definitely
like i wouldn't real i like i don't
really enjoy pixelate that much but yeah
um i think i would probably hire an
artist to do it like once we do actually
start kind of well yeah if you have to
do it
anymore then yeah
exactly yeah like at like at scale what
i want to be doing is sitting back and
kind of just
um
making sure everyone's working together
nicely and yeah i really like the whole
concept of um
just all just orchestrating like an
entire team and um just trying to
optimize that
the
um just the process of everyone
commuting communicating together nicely
um yeah
and yeah i mean that's that's that's
really nice and that's kind of what i'm
doing at the moment so i've got two web
developers working
on payroll uh on the website at the
moment um and then i've got
so i've got
two editors just for the second channel
um and they just help me like pump out
the stream highlights yep um
and yeah that's that's pretty much it at
the moment um but i like it like i like
i do want to expand that and um
definitely include the people who um
just generally want to do it and just
like volunteer but
yeah like i said i just haven't really
been comfortable doing that because i'm
yeah just earning money off it but at
the same time i should just not be a
[ __ ] and just you know let him do it
because it's like like it's that it's
their choice at the end of the day like
yeah
and i'm sure it'll transform them i'm
doing it as well
exactly yeah so
but yeah i think with the game it's also
like a little different
um
yeah um last thing i wanted to
uh ask you to wrap this up is
if you could go back like five years or
maybe even three years to when you
really started programming like
what would you tell yourself and
how has the experience i guess
changed
for you
what piece of advice would you tell your
younger self
i don't know i think
if i could go back in time and i could
just give my
give my younger self some advice i would
probably say
stop working so hard
um it's it's really not the end of the
day if you crank out more hours like
just just just try and be smart about it
right
and i would
if i could i would just would we just
slap him down into sea like straight
away and be like just focus on this and
just learn this right away because
you're going down that path
it's just i took so many different steps
to get there that
if i would have a mentor that would just
start me off in that spot to begin with
that would be great
so i mean i like but i can't do that to
people at the moment like i can't give
people the resources to go and do that
because there just isn't really any good
ones at the moment like i like i can say
all i want you know sure go and see make
a game engine and do all that kind of
stuff if that's what you really enjoy
doing um
but i just can't lead any people to any
good resources and it's kind of a bit
annoying but um
you know like it
it it varies from person to person um
just like in general like you can't just
provide this blanket statement of like
oh everyone should be making a game
engine and doing their own stuff and see
and all that kind of stuff because yeah
at the end day it's like what do you
really want to do you know what
motivates you to get out of bed in the
morning what do you want to go pursue
go do that don't let anyone tell you
otherwise you know yeah c is just a tool
um
exactly like you you you learn how to
use the tools actually i think this is a
this is a good wittle
and let me see if i can find the court
if but i came across this um hindu
problem the other day
and it was quite lovely quite applicable
to this situation
um it is
there are hundreds of paths off the
mountain all weeding in the same
direction so it doesn't matter which
path you take the only one wasting time
is the one who runs around the mountain
telling everyone that his or her path is
wrong
that's great
so doesn't matter how you do at the end
of the day all that matters is that
say you you've got this massive oz
mountain that you want to overcome this
is big hurdle
and you're worried about all these other
steps like steps 2 through to 100 just
ignore them just focus on the first step
take it get it done once you've done the
first one
then you can think about the next one so
just don't get overwhelmed and
just start just start what whatever it
is you want to do
just get going all right tell us this
podcast right now get going brilliant
fantastic words randy thank you so much
for being here on the podcast where can
people find you
just search randy and youtube i guess um
it's a pretty competitive search term
randy
like it was i've been typing in randy
gamedev
yeah yeah or if you type um aussie bold
gamedev that oh really
that works as well
um yeah so you can just find me over
there um
i'll leave links in there in the
description for those of you watching on
youtube yeah cheers and i mean hey it's
it's it's been an absolute pleasure
coming in this podcast like thank you so
much for having me like you know
starting out when i had just no
subscribers i was just like looking up
to you and watching your seatbelt spots
tutorials and to kind of just come on
here
it's kind of just like a full circle and
like yeah yeah it's amazing just it's
it's it's quite special so um glad glad
to be of help to you thanks for that's
why i make videos like that you know i
just i love i love that i love being
able to help people
all right thank you guys keep it up
catch you later have a good day bye
bye
[Music]